I remember like it was yesterday the  panic the hysteria  and then the acceptance acceptance that  earth was going to be destroyed and our  only grim consolation was that there was  nothing we could do to stop it  the neutron star collided and millions  of years of our history got wiped out in  an instant  [Music]  that's why they developed the rebirth  project everyone on earth fighting for  survival and a lottery among the fittest  to see who gets to live thousands of  light-years away I won and that's why  I'm here on this Ark ship  I'm a pioneer one of millions and our  job will be to rebuild civilization in  this new solar system  I've been frozen for the entirety of the  trip and now I'm ready to embark on my  journey  our journey  you